Horror is one of the genres most often maligned
by critics.
On one hand, that's because a lot of horror
movies are pretty awful, and they earn their
bad reviews.
But there are also plenty of great horror
films that happen to be critical failures.
The average viewer might avoid some of these
movies for their low Rotten Tomatoes scores,
but that number can be deceiving.
Here are just a few of horror cinema's critical
failures that are actually worth your time.
Lords of Salem
While 2013's Lords of Salem might not reach
the levels of exploitation nirvana that director
Rob Zombie achieved in The Devil's Rejects,
it's perhaps his most interesting project,
the surreal tale of a woman who finds herself
in the snares of a centuries-in-the-making
plot initiated by a coven of witches.
Critics slapped it with a low rating on Rotten
Tomatoes, complaining that it failed to deliver
the scares it seemed to promise.
To be fair, that's not an incorrect observation.
Relatively free of gore, the film is instead
something of an experimental tone piece, resulting
in a hypnotic, atmospheric film that's sure
to unsettle and intrigue viewers willing to
embrace abstract thrills.
Dead Silence
Considering the fact that James Wan's filmography
contains classics like Saw, Insidious, and
The Conjuring, if Dead Silence is known as
his worst film, that's still not too much
of a knock.
While far from perfect, it utilizes the classic
horror technique of taking things that are
already frightening in real life, in this
case, ventriloquists and their terrifying
puppets, and then making them the sources
of actual supernatural phenomena.
Even a middling horror movie is going to be
pretty scary when the protagonist is facing
a ghost ventriloquist who cuts the tongues
out of her victims.
"Your voice is mine now."
All things considered, it's admittedly not
anything special in terms of plot or writing,
which is likely why it didn't stick with the
critics who gave it such a low rating on Rotten
Tomatoes.
But boasting some great production design,
a perfectly solid cast, and a killer twist
ending, Dead Silence is still a fun little
entry in the filmography of a director who
has helped shape mainstream horror over the
last decade.
All the Boys Love Mandy Lane
Occasionally a movie's poor Rotten Tomatoes
score is less indicative of a lack of quality
and more an indicator of a film's divisiveness.
Among these films is All the Boys Love Mandy
Lane, which, according to The Washington Post,
was shot in 2006 and then delayed for seven
years.
It's a polarizing effort that boasts a critical
reception split almost down the middle.
Detractors felt it was nothing more than a
run-of-the-mill slasher movie, while fans
of the film praise its innovative visuals
and storytelling restraint.
The story centers around a group of teens
who invite the super-popular Mandy Lane to
a secluded ranch for a weekend getaway, and
quickly find themselves being picked off one
by one by a deranged stalker.
The movie seems to take no delight in its
kills, instead making the audience recognize
the gravity of each.
Even if you find the movie to be a failure,
it's an interesting one for sure.
Jennifer's Body
There's something to be said for a movie that
knows what it is, and the 2009 horror romp
Jennifer's Body knows exactly what it is:
the kind of film you'd watch with your friends
late at night.
It tells the story of a rock band's satanic
ritual gone wrong, leaving high school "It
Girl" Jennifer possessed by a demon that feeds
on the flesh of men.
"Jennifer's evil.
"I know."
"No, I'm mean she's actually evil.
Not high school evil."
Featuring a stellar cast, the most quotable
horror movie script in decades, and a killer
soundtrack, it's some of the most fun you
can have watching a modern horror movie.
"I am not insecure, needy, God, that's a joke.
How could I ever be insecure?
I was the snowflake queen."
Unfortunately, critics weren't quite sure
what to make of it in 2009, and it's got a
bummer of a Rotten Tomatoes score.
Jennifer's Body isn't quite old enough to
have built up a cult following or to have
received a critical reevaluation, but we get
the feeling it's coming.
This flick, like a fine wine, will only get
better with age.
Nightbreed
Advertised as a traditional slasher film,
Nightbreed confused critics by giving the
audience a dark horror fantasy that feels
more like a great young adult novel.
That's not to say it skimps on the scares,
it just happens to also contain the worldbuilding
and character arcs you'd find in blockbuster
franchises these days.
The story focuses on the human world clashing
with an underground city, the home of the
undead creatures known as the Nightbreed.
"And that means you're meat for the beast."
The film came out about 20 years too early,
and it found itself in the hands of critics
who weren't quite sure what to make of it.
While it sits with a terrible rating on Rotten
Tomatoes, Nightbreed is still very much worth
your time.
It's fun, innovative, and totally singular.